a potential turning point for kazakhstan
the president says the referendum will
decentralize the political system and
outlaw nepotism
it comes after peaceful protests over
fuel prices turned deadly
toppling the former president's
three-decade rule
but the proposed reforms have surprised
some and excited others
we were warned that there would be a
referendum literally a month ago and
more than 90 percent of our society do
not know or understand what a referendum
is
the importance of constitutional
amendments is obvious i came to vote for
the first time in my life and i'm 54
years old so for me this referendum is
very important i even wrote a request at
another polling station that they come
to my home so that my father who is 92
could also vote
the changes to kazakhstan's constitution
critics say will only bolster the
president's ambitions for a second term
there's a lot of questions about whether
this will really will reset relations
between the
state and its citizens which are pretty
traumatized after the violence in
january
the president also faces another
challenge staying neutral on the war in
ukraine while maintaining security and
economic partnerships with russia and
the west
julian wolf al jazeera